and finally new rule at next Thursday's
debate one of the candidates has to say
the problem with our health care system
is Americans eat [ __ ] and too much of it
all the candidates will talk about their
health plans but no one will mention the
key factor the citizens don't lift a
finger to help and then the candidates
will go back on the trail the next day
and try to prove they're just as big a
gluttonous slob as the rest of us
sometimes while discussing pre-existing
conditions but why do people have so
many pre-existing conditions being fat
isn't a birth defect nobody comes out of
the womb needing to buy two seats on the
airplane here it is in a nutshell from
the New York Times poor diet is the
leading cause of mortality in the United
States everyone now as obesity is linked
to terrible conditions like diabetes
heart disease and virginity
not to mention cancer but that's just
the beginning of it there is literally
nothing being overweight does not make
worse eyesight memory pain fatigue
depression you don't poop right it
weakens your immune system we scream at
Congress to find a way to pay for our
medical bills but it wouldn't be nearly
the issue it is if people just didn't
eat like [ __ ] who are killing not
only themselves but the planet the
Amazon fires are because farmers there
are burning down the rainforests to make
room for a future hamburgers and soy
beans because here in America we look at
fried chicken and think that's a good
start now put it on a bun and add bacon
and cheese and something don't even
thought to put on it make my mouth come
[Applause]
what's elizabeth warren's plan for that
Europe doesn't look like this because
Europe's not always eating for two we
weren't always like this watching the
footage of the 50th anniversary of
Apollo 11 I was struck by how not fat
everyone in the crowd was we look like a
completely different race of people now
look at us we wear shirts that our
ancestors could have used as a sail a
hundred years ago this guy was fat
enough to be the fat man in the circus
now he's a guy
people know I'm speaking the truth after
all is not why your tinder picture is
three years old can fat be beautiful
that's in the eye of the beholder but
healthy no that's science I know this is
a I know this is a controversial thing
to say now in today's America but being
fat is a bad thing we shouldn't taunt
people about it and overeating shouldn't
be singled out as the only vice it's not
we all have something but there's no
smoking acceptance or drunk acceptance
when I drank too much yeah sometimes
someone would say to me you know that's
not great for your health bill maybe you
should slow down a little you went kind
of hard last night and I would say yeah
I know I'm gonna start next week and
then of course I wouldn't but I didn't
say how dare you drink shame me being
blotto is beautiful of course I didn't
say that I was focusing on the road
when did it become taboo in this country
to talk about getting healthy Weight
Watchers had to literally take the words
weight and Watchers I'm not kidding out
of their name it's now W W because
merely the idea of watching your weight
is now bullying
what's next banning scales hey liberals
you know how you hate it when
conservatives won't even let the CDC
study gun violence as a public health
issue this is that you're the NRA of
mayonnaise we have gone to this weird
place where fat is good it's pointing
out that fat is done healthy that's
what's bad fat chain now we fit shame
really you hear it all the time someone
sees a merely trim person you should eat
something no you should not eat
something I should be more unhealthy so
you can feel better about your fat ass
in August's fifty three Americans died
from mass shootings terrible right you
know how many died from obesity forty
thousand fat shaming doesn't need to end
needs to make a comeback some amount of
shame is good we shamed people out of
smoking and into wearing seatbelts we
shame the metal littering and most of
them at a racism shame is the first step
in reform
it's what goads people into saying maybe
I can do better as opposed to I'm always
perfect the way I am how dare you we
need to start aiming higher as a country
this is a good place to start
we can all keep pretending that health
care is an issue between you and the
government but it's really between you
and the waitress it's not just about
being able to see a doctor it's also
about being able to see your dick
you